que emmanuel dupuy président de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe bonsoir emmanuel dupuis merci
d'être avec nous double fusillade hier
des attentats islamistes évidemment par
le passé on a entendu un gala merkel
dénoncé le poison du racisme il ya
clairement un problème de xénophobie en
allemagne en spécificité à la wii alors
ça ne touche pas que l'allemagne une
bonne partie aussi de l'europe de l'est
et je ne veux pas faire de corrélation
avec la crise migratoire mais il ya eu
en tout cas est monté une radicalisation
et dans la vie politique des pays
d'europe centrale et orientale est
évidemment de l'allemagne avec là aussi
des différences entre l'allemagne de
l'est et l'allemagne de l'ouest
si l'on prend le parti qui est
clairement xénophobe en tout cas qui se
présentent comme islamophobe et
xénophobe qui a été créé d'ailleurs sur
une autre base anti européenne l'afd
l'alternative pour l'allemagne qui a été
créé en 2013
accessoirement dans le même land où se
sont déroulées les attaques d'hier a
largement exposé il ne pesait que 5 % au
moment de sa création 12% à l'occasion
des dernières législatives
mais tonton va dans l'est du pays donc
les landes les moins développés ceux qui
n'ont pas totalement bénéficier de la
réunification en 89
il fait pèse de 22 à 25% donc on voit
bien qu'il ya différentes allemagne et
que ya différentes façons de concevoir
une radicalisation à la fois idéologique
avec la montée de l'extrême droite une
radicalisation lié évidemment à la
pérennité de la menace islamiste
l'attentât du marché de berlin en
décembre 2016 et le lan et wlan la même
phase si j'ose dire ouh là l'autre faces
de la même médaille
c'est à dire que l'allemagne doit faire
face à une radicalisation et je rajoute
que le terrorisme d'extrême gauche n'est
pas si ancien que ça la dernière victime
remonte à 89 et le mouvement notamment
la bande à baader la fraction armée
rouge ne s'est dissoute qu'en 1998 vous
parlez de l'afd
est-ce que son discours justement peut
être mis en cause clairement aujourd'hui
dans cette montée de la haine ou ça ne
s'explique pas comme ça alors je fais
pas évidemment extrapoler je ne sais pas
si la personne qui passait à l'acte hier
par le climat en général ces pertes
avaient par contre ce qui est une
réalité c'est qu'à l'occasion du dernier
congrès qui s'est déroulé il ya peu de
temps en novembre de cette même année il
ya eu un changement de génération avec
une profonde radicalisation au sein même
du mouvement
d'ailleurs le slogan que le mouvement
met souvent en exergue
cessons d'être des agneaux et devenons
des loups ou cessons d'être dépendant
des brebis et devenons des loups donc il
ya sans doute une radicalisation aussi
dans le narratif il il a encore quelques
semaines les services de renseignements
allemands ont évidemment pu arrêter la
diffusion d'un album à colorier où il
était précisé que pour protéger l'unité
allemande et fallait se débarrasser des
populations qui ne l'étaient pas en
nommant précisément la population turque
il ya trois millions de turcs qui vivent
en allemagne c'est la plus grosse
diaspora en dehors de la turquie dont la
moitié vote aux élections cela est aussi
important d'avoir à l'esprit et puis
bien évidemment avec un narratif qui est
de plus en plus radicale donc tous les
partis politiques au sein même aussi des
partis de coalition mais on dit souvent
que la séance où les plus conservatrices
que le cd ou comment expliquer justement
ce climat on a vu ces migrants arrivés
en allemagne qui était plutôt vu de
l'extérieur en tout cas plutôt bien
intégré le conte du travail
il ya eu voilà des cours de culture au
rheu on les a logés
comment expliquer ce climat alors le
stream a changé
n'est plus en septembre entre septembre
et cette norme et 15 pardon et le début
de l'année 2016 au cours desquels un
million et demi de migrants sont arrivés
en allemagne parce que l'allemagne les a
accueillis et la même axe et
accessoirement fait un appel pour qu'il
vienne sur le territoire allemand sur
ces 1 million et demi de migrants la
moitié ont trouvé un emploi
donc ça aussi c'est un élément important
comme j'expliquais il ya plusieurs
allemagne évidemment selon que l'on se
trouve à berlin ou selon qu'on se trouve
dans les landes de l'est ou de l'ouest
du pays on n'a pas le même regard sur
l'étranger maintenant la question que
vous posez amène à s'interroger sur le
modèle d'intégration allemand qui
s'apparente beaucoup à une forme de
communautarisme ou une forme de
communautarisation des différentes
communautés qui ont été accueillis au
fur et à mesure des procédés processus
de migration
deuxièmement cela interroge aussi le
modèle économique allemand qui est
nettement moins dynamique qu'il ne fut
par le passé cela interroge aussi sur la
stabilité politique
l'afd l'alternative pour l'allemagne
représente maintenant la troisième force
politique du bundestag avec 95 députés
cela impacte aussi sur le discours des
autres partis que ce soit la cd ou ou la
spd qui d'une certaine façon sont
facilement critiquable parce qu'elles
appartiennent mm coalition peut-être
verra-t-on des césures et des
différences d'appréciation selon que
l'on se trouve à gauche de l'échiquier
politique
chez les sociaux démocrates ou selon que
l'on se trouve à droite maintenant il ya
aussi la dernière réalité c'est que la
chancelière angela merkel qui entame son
quatrième mandat à la chancellerie qui
théoriquement devrait continuer à
exercer cette fonction jusqu'en 2021 est
fortement affaibli sa successeure homme
intègre et de crampes 40 bauer qui est
l'actuel mis la défense a abandonné la
présidence d'un cdo et defacto ne
deviendra pas la successeure de la
chancelière donc il ya une crise
politique qui fait dire à certains que
la chance nerfs ne pourra pas aller
jusqu'au bout de son mandat avec quand
même faut-il le rappeler l'échéance de
la présidence allemande de l'union
européenne qui devrait tête ou qui
auraient dû être
le dernier élément de testament
politique de l'actuelle chancelière
on voit quand même qui a une partie une
grande partie évidemment de la
population allemande qui ne souhaitent
pas passer certaines lignes rouges à
l'alliance à thuringe entre la droite
conservatrice elle a aidé avait provoqué
un séisme d'ailleurs le responsable
politique en question avait démissionné
ça ne concerne qu'une minorité mais
manifestement qui se fait entendre
ces derniers temps oui et c'est cela je
fais le jeu des partis politiques qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas au système de
gouvernement la coalition qui pour
l'instant regroupe le spd et la cdu ou
pourrait voir émerger une autre force
politique alors les libéraux parce que
il était question effectivement dans le
land de thuringe d'un candidat libéral
qui avait fait un accord de gouvernement
d'accord de gouvernement au niveau local
avec le responsable de l'efs des qui
évidemment a été récusé au niveau
national mais bien évidemment cette
situation d'un entre deux favorise une
force politique émergente que l'on voit
émerger un petit peu partout en europe
que l'on voir émerger en allemagne c'est
bien évidemment les verts qui surf sur
la vague de la non compromission de la
non corruption et d'un discours à la
fois base est évidemment sur la
protection des versements mais surtout
un discours vis-à-vis de la question
migratoire qui est beaucoup plus
réaliste et moins idéologique qui n'a pu
l'être vu de la cdu ou qui a joué le jeu
de l'intégration et à les céder ou la
payer chèrement puisque le dernier
attentat qui a malheureusement a été
mené jusqu'au bout c'est l'assassinât de
victor lookin qui était un milieu de le
céder ou sans jouer merci beaucoup
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe merci
à vous